hey it's Joey and welcome to better
ideas so final exam season isn't quite
here yet but it's just around the corner
and students everywhere
are just weeks away from entering crunch
time where all hell breaks loose
all-nighters are pulled etc etc anyways
one of the worst possible things you can
do in a situation like this or any other
similar stressful situation is worry
worrying is bad it's completely useless
doesn't do anything for you it causes
you to not think straight needless to
say it should be systematically
eliminated from your life
of course worrying is natural and we
can't really stop it from happening to
us every once in a while no matter who
you are but when it does you need to
learn how to control it
see through the fog of worry and take
action on the things that you need to do
with a clear head so without further ado
this is based off of Dale Carnegie's
book how to stop worrying and start
living here are three awesome tips to
help you eliminate worry in any given
situation not just finals step 1
ask yourself what is the worst thing
that could possibly happen if I don't
solve my problems say it's Sunday
afternoon and you realize that you just
wasted away the entirety of the weekend
doing nothing and in the upcoming week
you have 5 final humungous papers do so
the worst possible outcome in a
situation like this is to show up to
your class or all of your classes
completely empty-handed and your profits
to deduct 20 25 % or whatever your final
papers worth in that class really
visualize this happening can you picture
it step number 2 prepare yourself to
accept the worst if necessary so pretend
this actually happened to you you made
it through the entire week without
handing a single assignment in your home
for the summer
your grades start rolling in and you
notice that for every single one of the
classes that you didn't hand the final
paper in you're getting one two letter
grades lower than you thought you would
get in that class what you thought would
be A's and B's are season B's so take a
deep breath and mentally picture those
seasoned D's on your transcript except
that it actually happened you don't have
to like it just accept it
step number three calmly try to improve
upon the worst which you've already
mentally accepted now that you've
already visualized and accepted the
worst possible outcome calmly try to
improve upon it
worryfree take the assignment that's due
first start chipping away at it drink a
nice herbal tea
put your mind at ease and slowly make
that 0% paper that you've already
accepted into a 15% paper and then write
some more words blurb something out
until it's a d-minus paper even if
that's as far as you get and you make
one passable paper out of your five
papers you've already accepted that you
weren't gonna do any of them so in
comparison that's awesome you see by
doing this you're tricking your brain
into being productive with the clear
head just focusing on the task at hand
you're changing your chaotic panic
scenario into one of worryfree and
blissful clear-headed productivity now
which headspace do you think produces
better writing comment below which one
I'm just kidding that's an easy question
I used paper writing as an example for
this worry eliminating strategy but it
can really be translated to any area of
your life review next time you're on the
verge of a mental breakdown and it feels
like your world's falling apart around
you ask yourself what is the worst
possible thing that could possibly
happen if I don't solve my problem then
prepare yourself to accept the worst if
necessary then calmly try to improve
upon the worst which you've already
mentally agreed to accept if you follow
these three steps you'll be way more
relaxed and clear-headed in any
high-stakes scenario that's a good thing
if you liked this video and want to see
me make more be sure to hit that
subscribe button down below also leave a
comment because I relieve I relieve also
follow me on Twitter because I post
updates to the channel on the Twitter
and to keep you guys informed that's at
better ideas TV also we have an
Instagram page where we post daily
motivational quotes and that's better
ideas daily catching the next video